no yog on a sense of relief was palpable
in German Chancellor Angela Merkel's
final comments the CDU party leader
spoke of a party conference that was
good for everyone a conference that
offered answers on how to cope with the
refugee crisis I'm often Vic vai Dom aha
if we do take the path we've charted
will be able to do more for people in
refugee camps or conflict zones beyond
hero in clicks it watson's and knock
mouth knock some kite phonons become
earlier in the day guest speaker hosts a
Volvo chief of the CDU's sister party
the CSU had received a rather restrained
welcome he had made a show of publicly
taken the Chancellor to task for her
refugee policy at the CSU party
conference yet today Angela Merkel
remained cordial zahava praised the
CDU's resolution to reduce the number of
refugees entering Germany saying it
brought the conservative sister parties
closer together this is my universe oven
I'm convinced doses but without limiting
I need be careful repatriating although
for reducing the number of refugees for
refugee quota and we would definitely
prefer a limit only these if against all
but without that we will not succeed in
solving the problem in an intelligent
humaines and sensible way in the
foreseeable future from the point of
view of the population that's fine op C
bar outside the applause was subdued and
the Chancellor looked skeptical until
host zero fuk raised her perhaps to make
amends
llame knee we have a circle in
Chancellor it's absolutely possible to
discuss things with her the enthusiastic
applause was likely meant more for
Angela Merkel than for horse Seehofer
quite a taxi firm dippity was relatively
diplomatic but he probably also felt a
bit of a tail wind I know there will
probably always be something to fight
about but I don't believe that that
defines our two parties not at all God's
of Eliza every CDU party conference ends
with a German national anthem and this
one was especially harmonious at least
for now the party resolved divisions
over the refugee crisis within its own
ranks and to at least some degree with
its bavarian sister